hi everyone
um good afternoon welcome and it is my
absolute pleasure to invite you all
to the post talk discussion session
uh that we have for our monthly
colloquium series on
the inference project so as you all know
um
yesterday we had a wonderful talk by
professor jim with the role of
whether all of university of california
irvine um
and the title of his talk was why do
groups polarize
over matters of fact what models can and
cannot tell us
so you know we started with
uh and he started with telling us about
these four different approaches
and he outlined the limits and the
advantages of each of these modeling
approaches
to look at highly polarized groups of
people
and this kind of agent modeling um you
know give us a sort of an introduction
to some of these agent modeling
techniques which
scholars in the social sciences have
often used
in lieu of the kinds of simulations that
physicists
astronomers and people in climate
modeling and
other fields uh use sort of simple sort
of numerical models it's the new
kinds of simulations that help us
examine
social behavior so today
it is my pleasure to introduce our
discussant
professor kevin dorst who is on the
faculty of the department of philosophy
at the university of
pittsburgh where he is an assistant
professor
and he received his phd from mit
spent a year as a junior research fellow
at model in college in oxford
before starting uh this position and all
of his
research projects have centered
around one kind of meta big question
which is what should we think about how
people think and
you know typically psychology is a
discipline that
is used to answer this question
and psychology informs us that people's
thinking
uh that you know we are actually very
irrational as people
unlike the premise in often a lot of
economic modeling where we are supposed
to make rational choices
but um his work has shown that these
sort of irrationalist interpretations of
data
are actually questionable and they rely
on very simple models of what rational
people
would think and also these two contrasts
of modeling people as either rational or
irrational
and his work has tried to bring much
more philosophically
sophisticated models of rationality
to bear on the interpretation of these
types of empirical results
claimed in order to help assess the
degree
of irrationality and you know how uh
assess how irrational we really are
and so this sort of this this is sort of
his big picture of you
and his um its connection to
polarization in politics is something
that he explores
in uh his blog post a plea for political
empathy so i urge you all to go
and take a look at it and for an
extended argument that polarization has
its roots
roots in rational causes uh see the
series
reasonably polarized why politics is
more rational than you think
so i urge you to go take a look at his
uh blog feed which is
really really exciting and before we
embark on today's discussion um session
i just wanted to remind you about some
of our ongoing projects for which we
would
love your input and one of them is our
learning by doing projects these
simple experiments that can be conducted
by kids
supervised with parents or teachers at
home
so please consider either adding to our
roster of experiments
or sending us videos of your
kids performing these experiments
that's saying that our speaker in the
inference series for june uh will be
eric
winsberg and uh before
further redo i also want to thank our
benefactors
barbara and richard frankie for their
support of the frankie program
as well as many other activities uh at
yale
so kevin take it away please
thanks so much for um having me in the
direction i
i was telling jim before the talk this
is like ideal timing for me to
work on some of these computational
models too and have a lot of
big picture questions about what we're
doing when we're when we're doing them
so
i was thinking this would be a
opportunity at least for me to
to grill and learn from jim a little bit
someone who's been doing this much
longer than i have and hopefully it'll
be
um fruitful i also realized while
rio was giving that very nice
introduction that i found my first typo
on the handout which is that i forgot to
change the title of this handout
and so you might with that introduction
and with the title you might think i'm
gonna be going on and on about
rationality and actually that wasn't my
plan
we're gonna talk about a little bit
maybe maybe that'll come back um but
anyway so what i was thinking
i would do just in like the opening
comments questions is
uh just refresh everyone's memory on the
three models
uh that jim talked us through last time
trust conformity and reporting practices
and the big picture upshot he was um
sketching from them
and then used that sort of upshot and
sort of some of its
pessimism that i think he
rightfully um
introduced at the end as like a
launching
off point for like well to ask the
question what really we
can and should be trying to do um when
we're
using these sort of simple computational
models to try to understand
complex sometimes attractable social
phenomena so i'm gonna um
the handout i think is shared in the
chat um but i'm also gonna share my
screen just
for people who don't have it or can't
download it or walk through the handout
together nothing too surprising here but
just as a
anchor for where y'all can everyone see
that
um sharing screen up so yeah thanks
excellent um so starting just with a
summary of what
we talked about yesterday so uh jim
introduced three different models
that uh lead to polarization from
somewhat possible causes the first um
is trust dynamics so we have
a bunch of little agents on a network
that have some lines of communication
between each other they have to decide
which of two options
to perform option b
or option a option a they know it's
expected value
option b they're unsure of how good an
option is
the standard example is you know which
treatment should i prescribe to my
patients doctors might wonder
um and if you're interested in some
good example of this um jim and kalyn in
their
book and i think also in the papers is
based on your
detailed uh case study of uh this
uh what's called the lyme war is a
debate
over whether chronic lyme disease is um
basically is a thing whether um chronic
vitamin disease
whether lyme disease can that has been
treated with antibiotics can sometimes
linger and therefore get further
benefits from further antibiotic
treatment there's a
interesting polarized scientific um
arguably scientific community polarized
on that question uh
and so in that case you might think well
some doctors are deciding whether to
describe do i prescribe antibiotics or
something else
for this patient who may or may not have
chronic lyme so that's the sort of case
which is i think
where this model is most at home and the
way
this works is that they they learn both
from doing their own
tests or actions they just they take
some options a or b and
learn how good they are and try to learn
whether b is better but they also learn
from their neighbors they their
neighbors share information about how
their own tests went
and the the key twist is that
how much they trust their neighbors
depends on how close their neighbors
opinions are to their own in particular
how confident their neighbors are that
option b is better than option a is a
proxy for how much they
trust them and if they trust them less
they'll
update less or you know basically treat
their information as less reliable
than if they trust them more if their
credences are closer
and the upshot is basically that when
trust diminishes rapidly enough
based on how far people's far particles
opinions are
we often get polarization one group ends
up pretty confident that a is better
um they stop trusting the people who are
using b and
since they're doing a they don't learn
anything else about how good b
is well another group ends up certain
that b is better or arbitrarily
confident that b is better because they
keep on doing b and keep on
eventually getting evidence that it's
better
so that was the first trust dynamic
model
and so we end up with a polarized group
because basically sides don't listen to
each other anymore
the second model was a conformity based
model so again same structure we got
agent deciding which to do a or b
they're on a network they can learn
from their neighbors that they share a
link with on that network
um but now instead of having variable
trust based on the degrees of confidence
agents feel some pressure you might
think of as a social pressure conform to
their neighbors the people that they
share links with the people they get
information from and can talk to or
maybe trust depending how we interpret
those links
those are the people that they get some
extra
utility or value from doing what those
people are doing if everyone in my
you know social circle is a lyme
literate doctor
as they say and prescribes antibiotics
in response to
symptoms of apparent chronic lyme then i
feel pressure to do so
myself some and so i might be inclined
to do so even
if i don't believe that chronic lyme
is susceptible to antibiotic treatment
um and there was a basic result here is
that often
this doesn't lead to polarization but
when
the network has a particular structure
in particular when it has a click
structure
um it can lead to polarization so click
structure is where you have these two
or many different groups that are all
sort of well
interconnected but they are loosely
connected to another group
um sort of like that hopefully you
remember that how those look and the
idea is
well sometimes when you have this sort
of structure
um you can have a click of people that
are all doing
a and so they're not learning about how
good b is and maybe there's one person
on the edge of all these people are
doing a and there's one person on the
edge who
this click does b this person learns
from seeing these people that b
is actually better but they don't switch
their action because they feel pressure
to conform to their group
and because they don't switch then um
these people who don't have direct
connections this other group never learn
that b
is better and so everyone still does a
the idea is basically that sparse
informational connections between
clicks prevent the information
suggesting that b is better from
breaking into this
part of the network and so that's the
way we get polarization
in action and also belief sometimes many
of these people will believe that a is
better
or at least they can um
the third model then no longer had
a network structure it was based on
reporting practices of of media outlets
and
how those interact or might interact
with people's
response for information and tendency
perhaps to confirm their beliefs
so the model in this case we sort of
model
journalists are observing the world
they're
observing earthquakes or observing
economic consequences
or or what have you so some um
regular news that they can report on um
that is in some sense
representable numerical scale in terms
of how severe or how good or bad they
are
and they have different reporting
practices they have to select what to
report and they can
use hyperbole they can make things sound
more extreme than they are
they can use extreme reporting which
they just they only report on extreme
events one's very far from some
uh expected or neutral baseline uh or
they do fair reporting where they
they sort of like both sides journalism
where they have
whenever they give airtime to a bit of
information pointing one way they also
give our time to a bit of information
pointing the other
if we take those three different types
of
journalistic methods and then we add
that the agents watching them have
confirmation
bias of a particular form then we can
get polarization so in particular the
the model
confirmation bias is just that um
people sometimes ignore general the
reports of
journalists and how likely they are to
ignore report is proportional
to how surprising they find that report
so they at a given time they have
certain
um beliefs about um
basically how how likely you know the
the event there the economy
is to be doing well or badly or whatever
um
and how likely they are to ignore report
to scales with
um how unlikely they they probably
thought the report would be
and the interesting result then is for
certain types of reporting in particular
for
what you might call bimodal reporting
where um
journalists like basically report two
different classes of
bits of information um for and against
more or less so i think that falls from
either extreme or fair reporting or both
jim can correct me on this it's wrong
but
basically the idea is certain forms of
reporting that leaves a polarization
because people tend to pay attention to
the stuff that they
the cluster of information that agreed
with them
so those are three just to refresh your
memory on three different um
models of polarization we saw all prima
facie plausible
mechanisms that could be operative and
what's leading to real world
polarization
and so where jim ended his talk was sort
of
the question what should we make of the
fact that we've got these competing
models
of polarization and oriented
is a point that i think i agree quite a
bit with but i want to sort of launch
off from that point so
he says like look we shouldn't see these
models really as in competition what we
should see them doing is
identifying different mechanisms
mechanisms which on their own may be
sufficient
for polarization but can also work
together
to create polarization in any given
community so plausibly what's going on
is that
all these mechanisms and many more of
the sorts that other
models modelers have made are
contributing
to polarization once we realize that
that's
important and sort of frustrating
because it means that um we can't look
at the dynamics of any given model we
have even when we like quite a bit
and read off what will happen by
changing bits of the model
um and say that oh therefore get policy
interventions from there so the nice
example jim gave was
look you might think look at the
conformity model and think look well the
problem with polarization is that we
don't have enough communication
so if we add more links then the
information will spread to the network
and they won't be polarized anymore
good idea if this is your model but as
soon as you add distrust into the model
like from the first
model more communication actually can be
uh lead to
more polarization there's an empirical
confirmation of that sometimes when you
pay people to
look at uh disconfirming news sources
they they end up more confident their
prior beliefs
uh so the upshot then is that well look
we have these
we should be very cautious basically in
inferring either predictions or
especially policy interventions but the
effects of those based on any of these
models and we should see them in some
sense interacting
in a complicated way so i'm going to use
that then that seems totally right to me
and i want to use it as a launching off
point for the question like
big picture question then um which is
sort of
what is the role then given in light of
that complexity what is the role of the
simple computational models like these
of a complex social phenomenon like
polarization so
in particular given two um
two of jim's observations the first is
that there are of course going to be
many
sufficient and interacting causes for
that phenomenon for polarization
so distrust or confirmation bias or
conformity or other things and
jim mentioned this in his talk yesterday
in order to like sort of fully
understand the interaction effects of
of those it seems like we would need to
somehow try to combine and sort of
weigh those different factors together
into one
grand unified model but that seems
pretty plausibly an intractable problem
or at least we don't know how to do that
well
we know how to make simple models and
analyze their dynamics we don't know how
to combine a bunch of simple models to
make a realistic one
it seems pretty clear that as soon as
you get one marginally realistic
it's either going to be or probably both
going to be
computationally attractive but also just
um
inscrutable in the sense that there'd be
too many interacting factors it's hard
to
um know what's causing what um
and so harder and harder to test so
on that sort of pessimistic reading
uh sort of my questions of well what
should we be trying to do
when we make a model like this given
given those facts
um and i want to i don't think i have an
answer
i think i have some ideas um i think
we'll maybe raise some possibilities and
ways in which i think they might or
might not fit with um
what jim's thinking what the models he
was talking about are doing and see what
he thinks
about those possibilities if other
things in mind
and so on so um first up
option um sort of standard modelers
option we're giving how possibly
explanations where
what we're doing is basically uh saying
how could it be that polarization arises
and what we want to do
when we are constructing these simple
computational models is delineate
the maybe plausible ways that
polarization can arise in communities
that have various structures once we do
that with enough
different models we have a sort of
catalog a catalog of
sort of that allows us at least in
principle to like assess
the promise or risks of various policy
interventions so we can sort of appeal a
bunch of different models that say well
under this model here's what this policy
would do under this model here's what it
would do and so on
that seems good as a first pass but the
immediate problem and this is something
i think jim
surely agrees with that just there's
just far too many there's far too many
how possibly models um for um
how you could get polarization um just
to focus on confirmation bias i think
there's
more than probably i would think dozens
i think
i came up with a list of half a dozen or
more uh different models of confirmation
bias and how it could exactly it could
work and how it could lead to
polarization and
um making different predictions about
what sort of various interventions would
do so we need
we need some further constraints and
just that we're we're not going to
successfully catalog all these things
at least until we find some way to do
like a meta-analysis of models which i
don't know
question first question is that a thing
i feel like anyways i want to learn
about that
but um okay so
we need more constraints broadly i think
it's everyone will agree and so then
i think my other questions are basically
what should the constraints
how should we what constraints should we
use or which constraints are useful
to use option two here says well
take the hell possibly explanations
constrain them to rational models which
will be no surprise given the title that
i accidentally put on this handout
um so you know one one constraint we
could give is okay
can we show that polarization can or
will arise under
maybe even quite strong rationality
assumptions and that
can be used for one part at least in
part just because
many explanations of polarization appear
to irrationally appeal to irrationality
so it can
push back against certain explanations
or show that they're not necessary
and i do have some sympathy for for that
but it oh
we probably need more concerns as well
it's one one thought but
um i'm not sure question for jim
is that how jim wants to sort of
constrain things
like it sounded from the way he was
defending some of the models that he was
he was less
happy to try to um defend them as
rational and the confirmation bias is
pretty clearly not a rational
model even the scientific polarization
of the truss dynamics one
is you know maybe a at best a first pass
reasonable
proxy to use distance but from your
belief as a measure of trust but
surely would be if you put two people in
a lab in front of slot machines and they
actually follow those dynamics
you'd get pretty nutty results uh you
would think they were doing something
silly
um we can formulate a bottle i don't
know
the conformity model might actually do
better on this front so i don't hear
what jim thinks about that but
so that was one one approach is rational
rationality as a concern
another constraint we can impose is sort
of psychological constraints
or classical constraints it's like a lot
of importance so sometimes
um psychologists are pretty confident
about sort of what the specific
reasoning mechanisms are
that lead to polarization at least in
certain cases so there's
a good number of fairly robust if always
messy and contested empirical findings
that say under conditions
of this form here's broadly what people
do um and
that leaves them to confirm their
beliefs so confirmation bias is a bit of
an umbrella term that fits a bunch of
features that have this sort of
structure um positive test strategies
they ask questions that they they expect
yes answers to selective exposure they
look for information they expect
to be confirming bias assimilation when
given mixed evidence they interpret a
way that fits their prior beliefs
uh diagnosticity they tend not to care
about likelihoods in effect if you're a
bayesian
and and so i mean that's contested by
the way um but
all these are contested by the way but
um so there are a
bunch of specific reasoning mechanisms
which
um people arguably do or they sometimes
do
and one role for a modeler then seems
like it could be to like sort of
check the experimenter's intuition that
if they did this
it would lead to population level
polarization sometimes just obvious like
sort of ignoring information that tells
against your beliefs
um and listening information that tells
in favor it's like pretty clear
i mean we can check that but it's pretty
clear that's going to lead to
politicians
sometimes it's not obvious and wrong so
one of the one of the
um well-known instances of confirmation
bias is positive test strategy people
ask in fact
questions they expect the answer to be
yes to given their
preferred hypothesis um this came from
some waste and selection tasks and so on
uh turns out that just that doesn't lead
to predictable polarization unless
there's some other
error along the way as long as you know
what question you ask then
there's no expected polarization so
that's something that modelers can can
show and so that's one role modelers
can play sort of looking at the details
of psychological mechanisms and seeing
what their effects are population-wise
population level
so maybe that's an interpretation of at
least what the confirmation bias model
that
jim talked about is doing but i'm not
i'm not so sure and
maybe jim can can speak to this as well
so it seems
to me that if we're going to do this
sort of psychologically modeling that it
really is quite important that we
do our best to match the details of the
psychological mechanism in question that
we sort of
you know we have some particular
psychological mechanism we look at
exactly how it works and then
um see whether that leads to
polarization and
i mean i think the you know the the
model of confirmation bias that
they use which is sort of being less
likely to update information that
you find more surprising is maybe a good
for
first pass but definitely um there are
many more
details of the empirical story like a
beautiful story about how selective
exposure to new evidence
works the many moderators for it jess
wilson has this great
dissertation on confirmation bias which
i take every chance to plug that i can
um and um one just like simple
thing to point out is that there's
insofar as there's a drive towards
confirmation there's also a drive
towards looking at surprising things
uh that's what confirms a variety of
other finding uh
scenarios including for example when
people look at what causes
fake news to spread and um
if we model confirmation bias then it's
just being less likely update on
information that you find
surprising then that's at least in
competition with those other
mechanisms where surprises actually
leads people more be more likely to look
at that
information so um that's just to say it
does seem like there's a role for the
the computational models and sort of
lifting up computate uh
psychological reasoning mechanisms
seeing what they do at a population
level
if we uh apply them but it's less clear
to me that that's
what some of these models at least are
trying to do certainly
oh gonna ask about i don't know about
the conformity models maybe those are
are closer to them so i'll ask would
james could
jump in on that as well um okay final
final concerns i've gone for a little
bit too long here but
um final thoughts
for how we might try to further
constrain the space of fossil models is
to
impose further features on the sort of
polarization
where um or model
we observe empirically as a constraint
on what our models should allow us to
predict
um so one future classic feature
polarization just people who have
different beliefs and stability so
right but there are many other features
of at least many instances of real world
polarization which we might
um want to try to capture as well
um so consider you know
a classic example of a polarized
empirical question whether capital
punishment has a deterrent effect in
many of the psych studies that
people find confirmation bias use this
sort of
question probably a decently strong
opinion
on that here are i think arguably a list
could be questions
question but arguably three features of
that strong belief you have about
whether or not capital punishment has a
deterrent effect
first it's predictable not merely in the
sense that
it's predictable that people will
disagree about it it's predictable which
side individuals will end up and often
they can predict it too often
even if you're unopinionated on whether
capital punishment has determined
you can predict what your future belief
will be so just take a college student
who's deciding between a super liberal
urban college and a conservative rural
college they can i mean they probably
wouldn't think very much about this but
if they thought hard
and they thought about a little bit i
think they would pretty confidently
predict that if i go to this liberal
school
i can predict that i'm going to be on
this side but
anti-capital punishment side of the
debate and if i go to this conservative
school
vice versa um so that's a form of
predictability which is
um much stronger than just predicting
that there will be
two different factions it's predicting
which direction to give an individual
will go
um often polarization the second feature
is often profound it's not merely that
they're stable opposing beliefs but
they're basically arbitrarily confident
and that's possibly true of at least
certain maybe capital punishments invest
hard enough and bear with questions and
people are
a little less confident but anyway so
surely we could find others
here's one that i think maybe is
questionable what i'm inclined to think
is a feature as well
is that many of these polarizations are
robust in the sense that
people's confidence in their opinions
remains upon
learning good empirical stories about
how those opinions came about
so probably most people in this room
have read enough
op-eds and maybe psych studies and
whatever on how
confirmation bias works and uh maybe
they
certainly if they came to jim's talk
they have some idea of how these sort of
models of polarization
look they have some sense of what the
social science looks like when it comes
to explaining polarization
and i take it no one has changed their
belief on whether capital punishment is
insurance
no one's become less confident of that
upon reading some of it in the new york
times about how
confirmation bias works at least not
significantly less confident
and so that's i mean that's a
constellation of further features that i
think
many polarizations have and then
question do we have models which explain
those features
uh and here's them i'm going to spec you
a little bit
and this will be a good place for jim to
come in as well on here as well but um
i think that the confirmation by bias
model they give has
a and b but not c so a it's predictable
which direction you're going to go you
just basically look at where your prior
beliefs are and what
what media reporting practices are are
they bimodal or not
it could be profound because you could
as jim was showing you'd be more and
more confident in your beliefs
but i don't think it's going to be
robust and since as soon as you tell
people that well
what you've been doing is just ignoring
information from the other side
if they're minimally reasonable they'll
just immediately knock down the
confidence of their beliefs quite a bit
um i take it that's not what we do
some debatable authors because we're big
headed but we can come back to that
um uh conformity model i think has
c robustness and so you know what the
network structure is
and maybe even an a as well it's
predictable like if you're in a in a
click that's all a doers
being pretty confident you're gonna end
up in a do or at least maybe also an ape
believer
i don't think it's profound the sense
that the reason why we get polarization
is exactly that there's an information
damn
there's no more information spread so
people just don't get any more confident
beliefs they just keep doing what
they're doing
i think that's right you may be wrong
about that um
so jim do correct me and the trust model
it seems like well i mean it might it
might depend
i'm not actually sure about
predictability this is a question if
we start out you know at you know time
zero and we look at
the distribution of beliefs can we
predict who's going to end up really
confident
that b is better and who's going to end
up on the sort of at least with not
perfect accuracy but some confidence not
sure so
how's it randomly so i don't know
whether it's predictable actually um
it's profound in one sense one side is
arbitrarily confident the other
thinks that uh a is better and there i
think in general just like
moderately confident not they don't get
arbitrarily confident of that
and whether it's robust maybe a subtle
but at least if
people know that what's going on is that
everyone's just
sharing information that they have and
they're just trusting people based on
distance beliefs then they would know
that people are telling the truth and so
they would
uh then update on that information
and so it's not clear how robust it is
to knowing what the structure
knowing the comments so
that's my basically not
meant to the criticism per se as the
models i don't know if we really
there's a question whether you even
could have a model that would meet all
these criteria and i think that's a
subtle interesting question as well but
uh
an attempt to maybe try to go from where
we were at the beginning which how
possibly models are too unconstrained so
can we bring in more constraints to try
to further
uh control the space of where we want to
go or where we want to look and whether
adding these sort of features of
polarization or rationality or
psychological constraints could help
the choice of which models to
investigate so i'll stop there i think i
threw
about 1400 questions at jim i apologize
for those but uh hopefully we can get
some back and forth going about
some of these things thank you so much
kevin uh
that was really um a wonderful
dissection
with many um uh clarifications
as well as really important questions
for jim so jim please go ahead
yeah okay thank you so much kevin um for
uh
for putting together um these thoughts
uh there's yeah i mean so there's
there's so much to think about here i'm
actually gonna pull
the handout over to be in front of me um
so that i can uh keep it as a
guide here um you know i
i think uh there are
a lot of things to say it's sort of a
different at different levels
um so of the options
that you mention um
i i think of this as uh
somewhere between option one and option
three
with a a further possibility for
for um uh development that you don't
mention
so um there's sometimes in which what
we're doing here is how possibly
modeling um because
uh it's it's
these are highly idealized we aren't
trying to
um capture the the details of
the uh uh psychological phenomena
that that were
looking to for motivation or inspiration
um in some cases they aren't even
psychological in the sort of you know
folk sense of psychological more like
social psychological phenomena you know
there's
there's seems to be some some tendency
of people to behave in certain ways and
we don't know what the underlying
psychological mechanisms are for that
but it's an observed behavior and we can
extract from that behavior
um some some further information that
could then be a starting point for
remodeling but the models themselves uh
are are um
essentially how possibly cameron uses an
expression um
how
how plausibly sometimes she has a paper
where she
she draws a distinction between that you
know there's a kind of modeling where
like what your goal is is to show that
something that someone said was
impossible
can happen so um i don't know if this
example will help anyone but
there's a uh famous claim in the
early 20th century
sort um late early 20th century
uh that um language could never
evolve um because you can't evolve
language without already having language
and um one way of responding to that was
a um game theoretic and eventually
evolutionary game theoretic analysis of
uh how signaling systems can come into
existence
um through a kind of dynamical process
and the claim isn't that this is how
signaling systems actually evolved
it may have some qualitative features in
common with how they actually evolved
but that's not
the point the point is someone said this
was impossible
here's a scenario which you should show
it is possible that establishes that it
can happen now there's further questions
whether it did happen and we're doing
something that i
i like to think is a little bit more
than
that because no one is going around
saying polarization cannot occur
i mean it seems it seems quite clear
empirically that it does occur
um and so it's more like uh
let's let's um
try to understand whether the various
kinds of hypothesized conditions that
look like they might
be relevant to polarization um
can be seen to
actually bring about polarization um
uh even in simple cases um and so that's
kind of you know it's this is what
caitlyn calls
how how plausibly modeling it's not it's
not just
for the the the pure sake of
establishing
possibilities but it's a similar kind of
modeling strategy where you aren't
trying
to get anything approaching the full
complexity of the system you're looking
um
so um
yeah go ahead yeah it would be great if
we could just go back
yeah yeah cool so there's the thought
there like
um the difference
maybe between how possibly well at least
uh like
rule of thumb for the difference between
how possibly first how plausibly is like
um
is that anyone sort of wow
and how possibly you're just trying to
come up with a mechanism and show that
it could work and how plausibly it's
like
people have positive these mechanisms
and we want to verify that they actually
do what people think they do so it's
something
it's something like that i see what you
mean by sort of likes option three it's
a psychological one but it's not
necessarily psychological in the sense
of looking at the details of how
individuals are reasoning or replicating
that it's rather
looking at a maybe a high level social
psychological tendency and
making sure that it really is the case
that if you know people only learn from
their neighbors or whatever
people don't listen to people that have
very different opinions than that you
will get
polarization reserving the accurate
that's the yeah that's that's exactly
right so
that's the sense in which you know um we
we try to make the the case and you know
for each of the sorts of mechanisms that
we're looking at
that um we are
capturing some of the salient details
that seem to be present
in the real world cases that we're
interested in
and we're asking is that enough um
and that can sometimes happen not at the
level i mean just as you say not at the
level of
uh um sort of
the details of actual reasoning but
rather
at the level of what behavior seemed to
result from
the uh reasoning that that does take
place
um and
yeah so so
i mean i think i think you know as you
say there are lots of ways of modeling
confirmation bias there are lots of ways
of modeling trust
too um there are even lots of ways of
modeling how people
change their beliefs or opinions in
light of you know
interaction with their neighbors um
and i mean i i tend to think that even
you know bay's rule is not
i mean no one's doing bayesian
calculations uh
i i'm curious actually i mean i know
that different people have different i
think
uh i think some people think that they
they are
but i'm inclined to think they probably
aren't or they don't need to be at least
in order for it to be the case that um
strict conditionalization
is a good way of modeling the kind of
belief updating
in light of new evidence that agents are
doing
um and so i i would think of
uh the other kinds of you know so the
the kind of
um conformity calculation right we
imagine our agents are performing
a an expected value calculation and then
acting in a way that
um uh they believe will maximize
their payoff in the next round
um are people actually doing that
calculation is that actually what
happens when people conform
probably not i mean there's there's a
kind of um
gut level decision being made i would
think but it's also the case that
there's
trade-offs happening and this captures
that kind of trade-off and you know you
can ask well some of them
yeah some of the neuroscientists think
the gut level is exactly where all the
base calculation is going from
all the all the yeah all the expected
values are like
manifested as your gut is telling you
but i think
you will not have to go that far to yeah
well so
um yeah yeah you don't need to anyway um
uh
i mean something has to be happening on
um
oh look i mean if nothing else i mean
you know our our agents have
uh arbitrarily precise
we're not i mean they're they're floats
okay so they've got
you know 64 digit uh precise
credences which i think is probably not
perfectly accurate
as a representation of you know human
cognition but i don't think that matters
for
for what we're trying to do and i think
of the other kinds of
idealizations here as similar right
trying to find something that seems to
have the right kind of
qualitative behaviors at the level
that um they would need to in order for
them to
sort of be playing the kind of social
role
that is being explored in the model
um and so yeah so
that's that's it maybe that that one
question i had
when didn't bring up which is when um
in the confirmation bias model was well
what form of confirmation bias are we
doing is this sort of the ignoring
information or is this sort of being
biased and how you interpret information
am i right in thinking that you're
thinking brother what does it really
matter sort of either
either one is going to have some sort of
effect which has
uh information that doesn't fit my prior
expectations is going to be more likely
to be
play less of a big role in how i change
my belief so maybe it's because i look
at it but then i just count it in some
way that's the bias in life or maybe
because i don't even look at it
and we can we can gloss over some of
this psychological differences there
uh and use this model to explore either
one is that
is that how you think about the
conversation exactly and and i i'm
suggesting
there's actually there's another whole
framework for modeling confirmation bias
in the um
yeah the mathematical social sciences
literature uh
where you model confirmation bias is
just having extreme priors
um and you get to then make confirmation
bias a purely rational
thing you know capital r rational within
a particular decision theoretic
framework
uh but it doesn't involve
it you know ignoring or reinterpreting
or
or or changing what data you're updating
on
it involves just updating more slowly
um so
uh you know we're avoiding we're
we're suggesting that that that doesn't
actually have although it's you know
well entrenched
as a modeling procedure it doesn't seem
to me that it it adequately captures
the salient feature of confirmation bias
of several different types that we think
is is
operative in this case or at least maybe
operative in this case yeah
can i so like when you that seems right
to me yeah it seems like it's not just a
matter of extreme
priors
what do you yes what do you what's the
criteria by which we're then objecting
to that as a model because like you know
someone could then object as well to the
sort of ignoring data model which is
like yeah that's
that is a tendency people maybe have but
they also have the tendency to look at
surprising things and so like
how do we how do we um
you know whenever we have a
psychological tendency it's gonna be
because
humans are complex and attractive
there's gonna be 18 others that we could
layer on which may have
you know may reverse the effect um
so uh i think there are two things to
say
one is that the extent to which that's
true right that
there are other equally plausible things
that i could add on that would reverse
the effect
i i would see that as just a failure of
stability of the model and would
would make me much less confident in
drawing any inferences
at all from from a model with that
character
um but of course you know
like we have we're in a particular
epistemic position
where we know some things there's some
things we worry about some things we
don't know about yet we're trying to
figure out how it works and
you know we're just part way through um
and so
you know these models haven't been fully
evaluated for stability and one way in
which you might try to rule out a
particular mechanism as
a plausible one you have to worry about
is by showing that it's
uh it's not stable under small
perturbations that you think would make
it
um you know more realistic
um all right so the
i think i had i have a looming like ah
but
we don't want to end up with the models
and trackable so we can't keep on adding
things this is this is a strategy more
piecemeals but we have some model which
captures uh
you know this model of confirmation
there's the question well if you add
like a you know
add interest in the surprise does that
like counteract
the effect and when we can sort of we
don't want to try to model the 18
psychological mechanisms that could
interact with this but we can take one
and then
try adding the second one and try adding
the third one
piecemeal and see whether they so it's
sort of like a
pick from your slew of reasonable
psychological mechanisms and try to pick
as few as you can um
yes although the way that i think about
it is a little bit different just
because
so i think of these models as being um
tools
for reasoning in the sense that um
you have some somewhat vague ideas about
how
things are going to relate to one
another how these sort of you know
psychological or social psychological
phenomena that that you've observed or
that you know you read about in the
literature
how they work and how you think they're
going to work in a social setting and
now you try
to to extract from them some of the
the the basic features that you think
are the salient ones
and you set up a model in which you just
have those sort of simple components and
you see what happens
and then you get these results now
you're trying to figure out what the
results mean
um why these outcomes happen what like
what's going on you start playing with
the model and playing with the model you
start getting a sense of how within the
model
interventions are changing things um
which sort of gives you a sense of how
the model is actually working
which then leads you to you know start
thinking about how to interpret the
results generally and how they bear on
like the expectations you had originally
are you surprised by some things not
surprised by some things this exactly
what you expected in the first place
and often in that process you start
thinking
oh i see in this model we're getting
this result for that reason
but that's not really what's going on in
the real world that looks like it might
be an artifact
we should try to adjust the model in a
way that
you know removes that artificial
artifactual element
and see if we get the same kinds of
results you know to what extent is the
thing that i
now am worried uh was driving the
results but isn't really
particularly realistic like actually the
thing that's driving the
result and so it's not just uh come up
with a new
mechanism and add that to the model it's
more like in reasoning about how the
model works you learn something about
the phenomenon in the first place but
also something about the model
what's that that seems convincing to me
yeah i mean
yeah it's it's a dialectic process and i
think it's i mean
i think it's pretty common in science
but um
i certainly had that where like i was
expecting
[Music]
uh an effect in a model to push one way
and it turned out there was another
effect i didn't see coming which pushed
the other way and then
so that's why that can't yeah anyways
yeah and i mean i can give an example
from a paper that kayla
is working on with one of our phd
students right now where they discovered
that confirmation bias implemented in
one way in a network epistemology model
improved outcomes
and they were like oh
like what what's happened here
um and it seemed to turn
out that what it was doing was slowing
down
learning in a way that kept transient
diversity in some network structures
long enough
for enough data to accumulate
which in retrospect makes perfect sense
given the way these models often work
was not at all as i understand it what
they expected and now you have
you know it's sort of a a judgment call
on some level like
to what extent do we think that is
really a possible
uh role that confirmation bias can play
in real world cases and what would it
take to establish that and what extent
we think this is just an artifact with
the modeling framework
didn't didn't miriam solomon wrote a
paper arguing that i i don't know if
i've read the paper but something like
that like in the night like
that seems like a cool uh i don't think
it was a computational paper but it was
like
that confirmation bias that had this
effect of sort of
an example of plate tectonics i don't
remember the detail anyway so
i don't think i know the paper i think
there's a book
uh by two cognitive scientists
um that uh
i think advances some version of this
thesis
you probably know it um
yeah exactly yeah
i got a lot of questions that we're
seeing spur but we can oh
that's probably for another time uh
they're really questions for
kailyn not for me
um so there were a few
other things here that i wanted to to
um come back to here
uh so
um so the rational model stuff
uh this is a
i so i think
that understanding how polarization can
arise under strong rationality
assumptions
is um really interesting and important
um
i'm not
i mean all of the models that we're
looking at are sort of low rationality
models bound
rationality models or models where
um a strategy is adopted that's not even
boundedly rational
it's intended to uh you know
reproduce some apparently occurring
phenomena not not one where we have some
background justification for why that
that kind of behavior would be um uh
rational um but one that seems to be
happening
this is how i think about the trust
dynamics in when you
um we we
uh don't
you know scientists don't read papers by
people who they think
do dumb stuff so
what's with that i mean isn't this just
part of the literature
i mean well they i mean you get a waste
of your time but maybe you just think
that
it's not going to be be fruitful for
other reasons that you know even if you
had all the time in the world that you
wouldn't
actually get reliable information from
from it
um yeah i think that you know in cases
like that you probably can give a pretty
nice
full rational case where you sort of you
have a theory of what the other person
is doing and you have some priors about
how useful it's going to be
and maybe you do a cost benefit analysis
or maybe it's it's that
you know you think that this is all
noise no signal and
um but you know we aren't trying to
model all of that
uh and i think for you know on some
level it doesn't matter for us whether
or not
there's a story that you can tell in all
cases that gives rise to that kind of
outcome
um yeah so
i i guess this is sort of a question
back for you which is
um
it sounded to me like if one were going
to adopt option two you would need to
believe
that um
rationality wasn't just a normative
framework but it was a fully descriptive
framework for
uh human cognition and social
interaction
like are you committed to that i
certainly
don't want to be but i mean i guess
there's different projects you'd be
trying to answer one would be
there's a pure social bismarck question
which is like
does do rational agents polarize
and like you can you can be interested
in that question independent of what you
think about
folks like us now that's relevant in so
far as like
sometimes people will write arguments
saying
well look people are polarized and that
must mean they're being idiots
and so like in so far as it blocks that
inference then it's a interesting
normative fact
though and in so far then is the
mechanisms by which
insofar as then we move we
both have that normative thing and then
can connect it to
various psychological theories and so on
then
then maybe the case can be made it's how
possibly claim in the first sense that i
i
discussed right so how possibly right
yeah right before we shift theme we have
an interesting kind of uh relevant
question
from the audience sanjeev kumar asks
do you think we might be better off
focusing on the contextual features in
other words the nature of constraints
giving rise to polarization many of the
preference based
approaches to learn about aggregate
level features are based on
intentional agents and so they are
making uh you know i guess the point is
that they're making a strong assumption
about
free will do you think confirmation bias
emanates from a high risk preference
that's an interesting take
either of you take a shot at it go for
it yeah
there are some there are some
papers that are um some forms of i don't
really understand these papers off the
top of my head but that already some
form of ambiguity aversion uncertainty
about
what your how accurate your beliefs are
going to be something you can be averse
to and that can lead to
something like confirmation by so that's
something like a high risk preference i
don't
and someone at least as far as i
understand some of those models it's
it's a strange sort of ambiguity
aversion and so far as if you're like
have confidence 50 50 in a question then
you there is no ambiguity you know
exactly how
inaccurate you're going to be whereas if
your confidence 80 you're not sure
whether
because you you know the distance
between your degree of confidence and
the truth is 0.5
whereas or whatever your distance metric
is it's the same down the side
uh zero or one whereas in when you're
0.8 it's potentially different so you're
unsure exactly what your
distance is going to be and layer on
some level of
i think a risk aversion such as youtube
version and you get
surprisingly you get something some sort
of confirmation bias now that's another
case where i think
like jim said about the extreme priors
case i think that's an interesting
theoretical result
um doesn't seem super possible to me
that that's what's driving
uh confirmation bias for re i don't
think people
i think people if anything prefer to
have extreme opinions rather than
opinions around
point five would be what they have suck
so there's
there's some subtleties there um i don't
know if jim is anything
okay um
uh i i mean the main thing
i i'm sort of focusing on the first part
of the question of focusing on
contextual features
like the nature of constraints giving
rise to
to polarization um
and uh it does seem to me that
that um
so this is something that came up a bit
yesterday with a question that priya
asked whether or not
we can you know we ever ever sense that
that
you know one model of polarization might
be better suited to some particular case
than
than others um and
uh i think that
that the answer is is probably yes and i
think that
the right way of thinking about that is
um that you're you're focusing on
contextual features
and sort of your you know some
background understanding you have
of how the particular
issue is dealt with in the particular
social group that you're talking about
what the nature of the issue is what
kind of evidence is available how
information seems to spread
um and and so i think that in particular
cases we can
say a bit more sometimes even quite
quite a lot more
uh on the other hand um
that only helps a little bit for
some of the bigger picture kinds of
questions that we're interested in and
so as a purely practical matter if what
you're imagining
uh is something like well
you know
suppose you have the view that uh at
least
some of the the polarization that we've
seen in
uh the us and the uk say in the last
um 20 years has been driven by
new technology oh you mean um the
so that okay polarization not you're not
talking you're talking about the
response to say new technologies
um right so what i'm saying is like like
it's some combination of like the rise
of certain kinds of
cable news channels followed by the rise
of social media
has led to a feedback loop that has
driven polarization
right you might even say something like
well part of the problem here
is intentional decisions made by social
media companies to drive engagement on
their site
so there's a you know they're
incentivized to
maximize time spent and shares and
things like that because that maximizes
ad revenue and so
you want to promote um highly emotional
content or promote content that is
surprising in a certain way or content
that's
you may not even have a theory of why
you just you have an algorithm that
identifies what content seems to get the
most interactions and the most shares
and you promote that more broadly
you might think okay well that's
actually driving polarization now you
say
what kind of policy interventions either
as a social media company or as an
oversight
organization or as a government you want
to introduce
right at that level of description the
contextual factors don't
matter because you aren't worried about
polarization about vaccines or
polarization about covet or
polarization about election results
you're worried about polarization
writ large and it looks like you know in
general any or all of these
considerations could matter
and um i guess he has a follow-up
question if we use the framework of the
approach
avoid dilemma then confirmation bias can
come from avoidance behavior
yeah fair point yes i see that but you
know i
had a more kind of uh provocative
question for you both i mean
underlying all of these ways of thinking
about polarization
isn't there the assumption that people
are interested in the truth
could it be possible i mean and you know
as a question that is separate
from if we don't conflate that with
rationality
rational behavior and so on i mean what
if we were to lose that
premise that that sort of prior maybe
there are people who are not interested
in the truth value um i know that takes
us nowhere
in terms of modeling but i was just
curious
right um it seems like for example
um you know you often watch this is my
one of my pet examples
and um so you know you watch suppose you
go to youtube
and you say i want to watch the latest
spacex satellite launch that i missed
you go and look at it right
and then you know other things that you
might like
right along there uh is a flat earth
society link
that shows up right and that as you just
mentioned jim
and both of you address these questions
like you know social media et cetera
leverage so it's like you know other
related things that you might
these are not assessed for truth value
or anything it just shows up there
and so now this flat earth society years
their
whatever their link has the same
salience
in the rank choice search method that
google is using right so that it's
asking you
so and how can somebody
i mean unless you are not interested in
the truth and you're just
looking for an excuse to join some kind
of affinity group
of people who you know people who like
the color red
people who believe in the flat earth or
whatever i put all of those kind
it's that kind of how do we take that
into account
and and that um is there any way we can
model that or is that uh through our
hands and give up
i mean well stuff to say too i feel like
i mean
i feel like it's a great question and
somewhat
complicated one um i think for
for it seem it's definitely right that
people have many motivations that govern
what they see and
how they think that aren't just figure
things out uh that you're on youtube
you're on youtube you're probably not
like in your peak epistemic in
you know peak inquiry mode you're
probably like at best
sort of having a informative past
pastime
um uh so that's totally right
i i think it as far as
my read on the psychological literature
on motivated reasoning and motivated
cognition and
related phenomena that it it's rarely so
simple as that people
don't care at all about the truth it's
rather that they
have other things and then they somehow
those can push them to use
information that can convince them of
various things in certain ways so
you know i'm thinking of i think you
mentioned in the last session some more
by dan gahan as well which shows that
often more polarized people on a given
topic are the ones that
on various measures are more cognitively
reflective or more scientifically
literate they know more about an issue
and they are able then to rebut problems
with or you know
for but standard because i think as far
as i know the same thing is true in
general of conspiracy theorists that
like
anti-vaxxers or truthers about 9 11 or
whatever are people who in general
know a lot more than i do about vaccine
distribution production processes and
about what happened on
you know days leading up to september
11th and that sort of thing and so
in general i think certainly there
there's room to point to non-truthy
motivations and that i think that's like
some motivation for thinking about
you know jim's models where people care
to conform that sort of thing
or or or other i think those actually
might fit quite well with
some of khan's research um
but i think it it's too easy we make it
too easy on ourselves as the modelers if
we just think that can be
thought of as this person doesn't have
any concern for truth rather it's sort
of
it's filtered in all sorts of subtle
i mean there's a sense in which this is
this is you know
using a certain kind of decision
theoretic framework to describe
what people do um but there's a sense in
which
you know so for instance in the uh
in the the model that uses conformity
that that kevin just
mentioned um
the uh uh
they care about some truth they care
about what payoff they're going to get
and their payoff is a combination of
payoff due to their
true or false beliefs
uh their true or false beliefs about um
she's also about to go give a talk so i
think
um they're true or false beliefs about
the proposition at hand which is going
to have some
some you know lead to some actions and
have some some payoff
but also um they're true or false
beliefs about conformity because i get
to pay off from from that as
as well uh and
you know in some sense
um
[Music]
the way that i tend to think about it is
like people are motivated by something
um and they care about whether or not
the actions that they
take bring about the outcomes that they
want now they may not be able to
articulate what outcomes they want
the outcomes that they want may not
match up in the way that
you know others as outside observers
would think of as sort of characterizing
the outcome space
um but there's there's there's some
feedback from the world to any decision
that you make
uh and if you're just totally wrong
about what that feedback is going to be
um you know it
i guess some people are unhappy but i
mean it you're not it's not it's not
going to work out for you
right
no but i mean i i i like um
the um yeah i i like
uh i kind of understand and i get what
you're saying
both of you that you know that it is not
it's not like super useful to think
about
people being polarized uh
as some people not being invested in the
truth at
all because it really i mean they're
invested
in the truth but modulo
x y z and i think that's yeah so no i
get it yeah so i think that
um it would not be possible to classify
people's psychological takes as um you
know invested in truth
not invested in truth that's not an
access
that's useful yeah so um
i think um are there any other
um questions from anyone else or
um if not i mean i think we have a
little bit more time we have none of
uh you know 10 15 minutes and uh we can
continue
along the sort of uh points
so kevin i wanted to hear from you um
what your assessment is of the sort of
agent modeling approaches because i mean
jim kind of
told us what he thinks about their
limits their advantages
and what is your kind of take
of that kind of approach or
do both of you then the open question to
both of you is have you thought about
what other kind of mathematical sort of
quantitative
approach might be useful
uh framework yeah i could i can say it
yeah
i mean i think um i think i'm broadly in
agreement with a lot of things jim says
are very
for for many purposes sort of
how plausibly research program he was
describing seems interesting and useful
and sometimes surprising
and maybe more importantly tractable um
i actually come at this from slightly
differently i come from a um
more analytic formal epistemology side
of things where we're using
um it's much more less computational
based much more proof based much more
detailed
models of detailed rational models of
individual agents it's closer to the
microeconomic equivalent if this is
macroeconomics
microeconomics and
so coming from that background the way i
found
um kind of these sort of computational
models useful
in a slightly different way or from
slightly different angle perhaps than
jim does it now that you now that i
think about
possibly informs most of my questions
which is uh
using the models to lift up those other
techniques so there are sometimes you
have a
model of how individual and individual
reasons or how they update on evidence
or whatnot uh
but it very quickly becomes interactive
when you think of how they're going to
do it over a long period of time or
maybe with many other interacting agents
not something you can
write down proofs very easily about uh
at least except in very special cases
and so the
one very useful thing for computational
models that often just simulate
simulate it and see what happens um when
an agent who acts in this way
which you've specified and argued makes
sense or whatever or at least
actively describes psychology in this
sort of scenario see how that that will
evolve over time and
this is the thing i mentioned earlier
with jim where i you know analytically
had some hunch that
would go one way and in fact once you
simulate it goes a different way because
they're multiple competing factors so
that's one way in which i feel like it
it
can be useful not not i wouldn't want to
say certainly the only way
but as a way of lifting up either
psychological or
other motivated sort of microeconomic
style models of individual reasoning and
seeing what the effects are
when iterated or writ large um so that's
i mean
that's the way that combined some of
some different mathematical techniques
with
uh computational ones
um i also have a
list of other questions i can pepper gym
with if we want to
i mean so i'm i'm hearing priya's
question in part
um in the context of um
you know how to think about agent-based
modeling in comparison with
various simulation methods in other
areas of
science yeah um
and so you know
even in the kind of example that kevin
just discussed there are a few different
things you might
be thinking of doing with the simulation
right so one is you just have some
computationally intractable
problem and so you solve it numerically
and that's the sort of thing that we
sometimes think of as a
simulation in some areas of uh science
um you might also think about
you know um
yeah yeah okay so we just
leave it at that um you know there's
sort of
a general slew of different
computational techniques that you could
bring to bear on problems
um and you know there are uh sort of
intermediate cases where it's not
totally clear whether you should think
of something as an agent-based model
or not um the way i usually think about
asian-based models
is that uh you are i mean
you're you're you're thinking of them as
um a collection
of individuals parameterized in some way
that have some dynamical properties
uh you know
arguably cellular automata are
asian-based models on that
definition but that's not that's not
people how usually people think about
them and so you know okay so just what
is it that makes an agent-based model
really an agent-based model and i'm
i think you can very quickly come up
with um counter examples to virtually
any definition you could
could give even though we have a pretty
good general idea about how they work
um but i mean look you know think about
like
you know um particle mesh type models in
cosmology
there's a sense in which we're talking
about particles but it's also the case
that we aren't representing
particles we're representing regions of
phase space and that they behave kind of
like particles from one point of view
right and so you know there's some sense
in which this is a
[Music]
just a numerical method for solving
certain complex differential equations
um which themselves have an
interpretation as governing
small bodies acting in the collective um
but
you know um i mean there are proxies
they are proxies with convenient
properties for numerical manipulation
basically right
no because i i wondered whether i mean i
guess
part of my question is whether you know
is there a just an
information flow approach
um that could be used
um could we just make maps of
information flow and you know
intersections between those maps
collisions between those bits of
information or whatever
i'm just trying to see if there are you
know if one were to
model what is it the transmission
of that causes that ends in polarization
and so on i'm just you know um
freewheeling here
trying to see what kind of approach
might be an interesting
new way because you know one of the
goals of our longer term project is
really to try
sort of try and understand what are the
ways in which we can
depict complex processes from which we
are able to pull out
causation we're going to infer causation
from correlations
and deeper correlations how do we kind
of how do we characterize
complex systems in terms of
the causal relations between entities
that
are part of the modeling scheme so i was
just curious like in a meta way
you know is there a sort of another
are there other approaches we could
consider
yeah i mean jim might know more on that
i feel like i sort of sometimes think of
the some of the agent-based models that
jim was describing as doing something
like giving a map of information through
how does information flow uh flows from
people saying and doing things
and so when we think of and people are
connected in certain ways via
maybe networks of trust or communication
or
interaction and then we can model that
as you know social
sort of like the you know the the two
models jim was using the first two that
have
been in the control so the network
graphs kind of models right the network
graphs kinds of models of uh
maybe driven by uh uh computational
um uh tractability considerations
but where you go from uh
very complicated networks and very
simple rules for how information
propagates on the network
to very simple networks maybe just a
single agent or a small handful of
agents and complex psychologically
realistic models of how
those agents process information yeah
which are themselves often network
models right you know like a bayesian
network representing
the single agents right but that you're
you're sort of
um you know there are modeling
frameworks that
uh use very very simple dynamics for how
information propagates so for instance
um epidemiological models
are often used in social epistemology
less so by philosophers but often by
psychologists social psychologists to
study the flow of
um information and what happens is
basically you know you have either some
very complicated network or just
random pairwise interactions and there's
some probability of some
transmission you can think of that as
modeling information flow through a
network or through some population
kevin we do have a few more minutes so
if you have any
um last points that you would want to
discuss
and bring up with jim please go ahead
yeah i mean there was one
i mean small questions i threw out jim
which maybe i won't bore people with but
that
there's one question i had that
related to what jim was saying at the
end of his talk it may be somewhat less
related to some of this discussion but
um and so far as he
was worried about this you know the
initial worry for the three different
models explaining polarization was
uh well are they competing uh they're
they giving different explanations
and so does that mean they're in
competition in some sense one question i
had when
thinking through the models at first was
um
basically to what extent we can see them
all as arising from one root cause which
is
is trust in some sense so like when we
think about the conformity
model in particular like in many
contexts like what what does a link
represent
in a context where um or what a model
these people is doing a or b and they're
they're learning from some
people and not others well if we're
thinking about a political creation like
that it better not just be lines of
communication because communication
is cheap everyone can commute with any
everyone nowadays it's got to be
something more robust and one natural
thing is
the lines of trust they're the people
that you listen to and so like
in this little model the reason why this
there's no link between these two is not
because this person can't see what this
guy is shouting it's just that this
person doesn't trust that person
um on that interpretation then it looks
like the
the conformity network
models might have very similar
motivation
and very similar driving force
underlying them
that to the trust dynamic ones and
likewise you might even think with
confirmation bias why is it that you
people tend to disregard information
that they find is surprising well big
reason is that they don't trust it like
when when breitbart comes out with a big
news story about like what the clintons
were doing in
you know mid 90s or whatever i think ah
that's pretty questionable i'm not
probably not going to listen to that
because that and the reasons i don't
trust them as reporters
um and so
i mean maybe you know that's a
unification without
the potential to get unification a name
without unification substance i mean
trust can have very different
meanings in different contexts but i was
wondering if
there is some deeper unity that could be
had within these
class of models in some sense trust
drives
yeah i mean i think that there are a lot
of interesting things that one could
say or think about more here one remark
is just there's an interpretation of the
trust model that we presented
where it's a dynamical network model and
really what's going on
is we have um either you know
everyone is connected to everyone but
the strength of connection moderates
over time as a function of distance and
belief
uh um or you could even think of
of it being a kind of a literal distance
you know people are arranged and some
uh um
grid and uh move
in belief space over time and listen to
others based on
their actual distance in that space do
you all see
the scary new york new york times of the
thing that like is mapping polarization
within cities like within cities you see
these like massive
uh red and blue sections so once this
came out earlier this year it's
fascinating
yes like literally space sometimes
correlating with blue
um right but i mean
there's also there's the like what's the
causal direction
oh yeah yeah it was all there right yeah
but i mean
i i think so so i think that there's
something to that nonetheless i
also think that um
you don't need to think about the uh
connections
in the um conformity model
as representing trust you can interpret
them
as for instance literal geographic and
you know
inaccessibility or you know there's been
a lot of theorizing
about what happens on the internet some
of which have been debunked actually but
um where you know you have this idea of
filter bubbles where there's literally
um you see different content and you
you it's very difficult to gain access
to the other
kind of content um
and you know
that leads to an interpretation of the
conformity model
where it really is that you're not
seeing
everything that other people are putting
out you're right that it's not that you
can't in principle
overcome that um but uh
um it's sort of the first order not what
you're exposed to
and so i think it's interesting that
even if you don't have i mean there may
still be some underlying
level at which trust is coming in like
why is this the social network that
you've built
or why is this um
you know why has your what they call
um a news diet or media diet
shaped in the way that that it is that
has to do on some
other level with with trust um
but it turns out that just you know
differential exposure is sufficient even
if it's not trust-based
and so i think that that's an
interesting upshot
um even if there's some you know other
underlying explanation that makes this
really more about trust and it's
presented in the first
instance
yeah yeah that sounds like one could
diffuse
even if one could diffuse the worry that
these models are incompatible by saying
well they all actually stem from the
same thing
it's maybe not wise who because the the
general point about even if they
did have different cause even if we
certainly interpret this as geographic
location or whatever then uh they could
be the point that they can be sufficient
not competing in interacting causes
would be right
we seem to be at a moment of uh natural
pause let me quickly check if there any
other questions have come up
um in the chat i don't see
anything um so i i
i guess um it's time to say thank you
to both of you for a really nice
useful clarifying and fun discussion
wouldn't be wouldn't it be wonderful if
we
had uh a solution to uh
helping um understand uh
polarization i think you know
polarization is probably
inevitable to some degree or the other i
guess it's part of human psychological
emotional intellectual diversity
that we may have to live with but
the kind of extreme levels of
polarization have been so detrimental
to society and culture and in particular
the polarization around science and
around facts
and reason have been deeply disturbing
in the last couple of decades so
i want to thank you both kevin and jim
for
this really wonderful afternoon it's
been a real privilege
to uh listen to both of you discuss
and it's a treat that we were thankfully
able to replicate
in this virtual situation
and in many ways i think while the
pandemic has
really thrown a number on many of our
approaches to interacting and convening
one of the good things has been the
reach
and the possibility to get people uh
without leaving a common footprint well
not as big a carbon footprint took to
convene and converse so thank you both
uh
to uh and by uh to irvine and
in pittsburgh um uh
and have a wonderful um uh weekend
uh a long weekend thanks everyone i want
to
thank the audience for attending and
participating in this uh
fabulous event and i want to thank uh
tai for helping
organize this and to guide for helping
with all the av
so bye everyone have a look bye
everybody
thank you